[Musique]
chantal hébert hélène buzzetti alec
castonguay bonsoir à vous trois bonsoir
bonsoir je remonte rapidement un petit
tableau assez simple sur les faits
saillants déficit prévu de 5 ans 2,8
milliards plutôt que les 58 qu'on
envisageait le celi pour la première
première propriété qui est peut-être
l'élément donc qu'on va retenir s'en
mêle nouveaux logements programme de
soins dentaires gratuits ça c'est le
résultat du pacte avec le npd et pour la
défense 7,2 milliards de plus sur cinq
ans non le canada ne va pas atteindre 2%
avec son premier tour de table rapide en
entrant la chambre des communes madame
frais l'année monsieur trudeau ont fait
8 détour linguistique pour vraiment dire
vous savez là n'oubliez pas que si
responsable c'est pas parce qu'on
dépasse ça sera responsable ça sera
responsable ce sera responsable est ce
que chantal hébert je commence avec vous
c'est un budget responsable ou
c'est obligé davantage dépensiers c'est
bon ça c'est un jeu auquel on joue pour
arriver à déjouer les attentes et
clairement ce budget-là déjoue les
attentes dans ce sens où les
conservateurs cet après midi avec leurs
commentaires ce budget responsable et
cetera avait préparé le terrain pour un
bar ouvert et ça l'a rejoint tout c'est
pas la première fois rappelez-vous des
vaccins et ce n'est pas un bar ouvert je
pense que au niveau des communications
les libéraux sont exactement les types
qui donnent même dame national post à
principal prôné que c'est pour dire un
budget raisonnable et ça veut dire que
donc quand on gère des attentes on va
vous dire que ce but tu aurais pu être
écrit par des conservateurs
avec l'appui du npd est en plus
monsieur singh dans ses réactions joue
d'entraîneur sans problème en disant
finalement au final ça va exact c'est
quand même intéressant hélène et
comme dit chantal y avait un jeu des
attentes les gens s'attendaient à un
buffet gargantuesque à rouen au sol je
me suis demandé c'était un hasard que
mme adam freeland soit tout de bleu vêtu
aujourd'hui le bleu très conservateur le
message était farrell qui porte toujours
des robes plutôt rouge ou allah je
m'attarde pas cette analyse
attention c'était parce que c'est du
temps changeant
mais quand même il y avait un message
oui c'était un budget de retenue
effectivement parce que les attentes
étaient très élevées mais à cause de la
campagne électorale il y avait beaucoup
de promesses dans cette campagne pour
soixante dix huit milliards bon oui pour
tout tellement d'hommes est néanmoins on
s'attendait à beaucoup de dépenses là
dedans et plusieurs d'entre elles n'y
sont pas je pense évidemment à tout le
volet de la santé il était exposé
d'avoir des milliards et ils ne sont pas
tous au rendez-vous incluant par exemple
ce pour réduire les listes d'attentes
dans le domaine des chirurgies là quand
la promesse électorale les libéraux
était de donner tout de suite 6
milliards de la première année on est
plutôt au tiers de sa 2 milliards alors
bref oui c'est un jeu d'attentes mais on
sent qu'il ya une certaine retenue dans
ce budget est d'ailleurs les hauts
fonctionnaires qui sont venus nous en
parler pendant le huis clos nous nous
l'ont dit il ya beaucoup beaucoup
d'incertitudes à cause de l'inflation à
cause de la guerre en ukraine à cause
encore des changements climatiques et
donc on sent qu'on a peut-être voulu
faire attention alec depuis la mise à
jour du mois de décembre le gouvernement
grâce à la bonne tenue de l'économie
puis à l'inflation qui est très élevé
ont réussi à engranger 2 36 milliards de
dollars de plus que ce qu'on prévoyait
en décembre dernier et de ce 36
milliards là on en dépense seulement 5
milliards cette année donc la marge de
manoeuvre christophe willem ne l'a pas
utilisé en nouvelles dépenses elle l'a
utilisée pour réduire le déficit
essentiellement et donc on aurait pu
avec cette marche demain blog arguant
dessus est dit bon on va créer des
programmes on remet de l'argent c'est
assez c'est assez contenu même l'argent
pour la défense le 7 pour 1 2 milliard
sur cinq ans de plus que prévu c'est pas
énorme compte tenu de l'aider ce que
l'otan de membres de ce que la pression
populaire demande étant donné l'ukraine
donc on a vraiment été très très prudent
du côté de christophe willem c'est un
budget assez différent de ce à quoi nous
aurons nous ont habitués les libéraux de
la précédente mouture avant la dernière
campagne électorale même le programme de
soins dentaires bon faudra négocier avec
les provinces est toujours difficile de
savoir exactement combien ça va coûter
ma 5 milliards de dollars sur cinq ans
c'est pas un nouveau programme très très
coûteux par rapport à d'autres
programmes comme les garderies par
exemple qui à terme peut coûter une
fortune de 30 milliards par année donc
on est vraiment le candidat des cibles
tout à fait
raisonnable on dirait les libéraux de
l'ancienne mouture et non pas ceux du
justin trudeau dans quelle mesure parce
que il avait les coudées franches
contenu de l'entente avec le on
n'avait pas besoin d'en faire autant
justement on est on sentait plus les bhl
chantal bon deux choses fausses selon
mes calculs c'est le premier budget
depuis 2008 où on sait pas un budget
très lecteurs et c'est pas un budget
pandémique est alors ça ressemble à un
budget
mais c'est plutôt ça d'une part d'autre
part oui c'est vrai c'est le budget d'un
gouvernement qui s'est acheté du temps
et qui pense pas avec raison qui seront
qu'un prix campagne électorale donc
toutes les espèces de fioritures qu'on
met autour des budgets
moins un petit peu moins de verbiage
c'est toujours bienvenu
mais c'est le budget d'un gouvernement
qui se donne le temps et qui donne le
temps au temps et on a vu monsieur singh
qui fait la même chose ça a été le
contraire eût été étonnant d'ailleurs
mais
j'ai rarement vu cela dit un budget où
il y autant de ficelles à attacher qui
ne le sont pas et c'est dans à peu près
chaque poste de dépense
et l'année alex sur cette même caisse de
cette liberté du temps qu'on a qu'on
s'est donné grâce à l'entente ça
transparaît effectivement le mot classe
moyenne ne revient pas à chaque
paragraphe là oui oui on est très
content que le budget ne fasse que
quelques centaines de pages plutôt que
quasiment à 1000 de la dernière fois le
stand une sacrée briques mais la
ministre elle-même l'audi quand on lui a
posé la question en point de presse plus
tôt aujourd'hui pourquoi toutes vos
promesses électorales ne s'y trouve pas
l eau du bain voilà c'est le chapitre 1
de quatre chapitres dit que le premier
oui effectivement cette entente avec le
npd lui permet d'avoir plus de temps et
justement de voir venir les choses selon
cette incertitude que l'on nous dit
figurer à l'horizon c'est vrai qu'il
manque beaucoup de détails sur plusieurs
mesures je pense par exemple à une
réforme sur l'assurance emploi on nous
dit ça s'en vient mais quand bof on nous
dit aura des consultations et quand les
consultations seront terminés on
déposera un plan ça nous donne aucune
idée de quand c'est ça on parlait tout à
l'heure de l'assurance dentaire
effectivement il ya aucun
aucun mécanisme ne dit pas comment on va
faire ça mais on nous dit quand même que
ça va être cette année ce qui moi
m'amène à penser que probablement qu'on
va fonctionner seulement par crédit
d'impôt donc essentiellement vous allez
envoyer vos factures à ottawa lors de
votre rapport d'impôt pour peut-être
tourné à obtenir un retour ce qui
éviterait des chats mariage avec les
provinces mais ce qui ferait je viens
sur wii et on verra par contre parce que
si c'est comme ça qu'on procède et bien
pour les familles les moins nantis à qui
s'adresse d'ailleurs ce programme et ben
sahar est pas nécessairement le problème
parce que lorsque vous êtes dans le
cabinet du dentiste vous les avez
peut-être pas les 2 3 400 dollars
nécessaires pour payer la facture tout
de suite oui alec vous êtes d'accord
c'est bien mais nous aussi nous disait
tout à l'heure ça ressemble selon temps
qu'on n'avait pas vu un budget qui
ressemble un budget que c'est pas on
veut on n'essaie pas de plaire à tout le
monde pour voisin puis à l'autre il ya
quelque chose de plus simple et
peut-être deux
direct en tout cas d'un budget de
gouvernement majoritaire majesté sont
générateurs alors ça transparaît de la
manière dont ils gouvernent est-ce qu'on
va être capable comme le dit linda s'est
rapidement de mettre en place
l'assurance dentaire moi je suis pas
certain c'est à dire que c'est très
variable d'une province à l'autre ce qui
est couvert par
pour les soins dentaires par exemple au
québec les enfants de moins de 10 ans
c'est presque la gratuité totale alors
qu'en ontario mais ça va juste 17 ans
mais foi est une famille à faible revenu
avec deux enfants pour faire moins de 26
mille dollars de revenus alors là on
peut il va y avoir de l'arrimage quand
même à faire avec les provinces pour que
ce soit un peu plus uniforme mais ce
qu'on envoie un chèque à québec qui a un
programme plus généreux alors combien ça
va coûter un bout de piste on calcule à
peu près un milliard par année j'ai hâte
de voir si la facture finale vont être
vos rassembler la somme donc les
ficelles à attacher non par et chantal
ça en fait partie a de plusieurs comme
ceux qui pourraient faire varier le coup
mais on a de l'âme en est on à la marge
de manoeuvre on a quand même on est
capable s'ajuster dans les prochaines
12 milliards du puits prévus il ya six
mois entre genres fait un tour de table
français que vous alex türk est ce que
ça nous dit sur les négociations avec
les provinces transferts en santé par
exemple cet énoncé budgétaire allait ça
va être le grand classique des provinces
qui vont se battre plus farouches manque
d'autres pour être capable de garder le
tonneau mis en matière de santé dentaire
le québec va pas accepter qu ottawa
finalement commencé à avoir son propre
programme on va vouloir l'argent comme
avec les garderies on m'a demandé que ce
soit sans condition on verra si le fait
que la campagne électorale fédérale
n'approche pas autant que la précédente
ici on voit aussi bien disposé envers le
québec qu'on l'était pour les garderies
alors que dans d'autres provinces on va
être bien contacter le fait des récents
n'occupe pas ce qu'on a à peu près rien
en place généralement sur les sur cette
demande des provinces se monte à 38 %
sur la santé au vin ça ça va prendre une
négociation séparée en bonne et due
forme on n'allait pas avoir d'argent
dans le budget pour ce ça va vraiment
prendre le nom de négociation assez
serré les premiers savent qu'elles
obtiendront poli 28 milliards de dollars
de plus par année qu'elle réclame mais
probablement que ce qui a été annoncé
aujourd'hui qu'ils plus généreux parce
que le pib les flashs le pib nominal est
plus élevé les provinces devront savoir
plus d'argent santé mais l'oeil en
veulent encore plus ça va prendre une
négociation séparée et là j'ai un peu
l'impression que c'est bataille avec les
provinces ont reporté un peu plus tard
justement pas à cause de tout ce qu'on
disait ou pas auparavant à savoir que
les dépenses vraiment ciblé pour
recruter des médecins et la santé
mentale les soins à de longues durées ne
se trouve pas dans ce budget est vain et
ses dépenses seront vraiment dans chat
p2 ou chapitre 3 il est donc pour
l'instant on voit pas nécessairement de
programme qui nécessite de grosses
négociations oui la question des dents
pourrait en être un mais mais si on
procède comme je disais par les crédits
d'impôts on pourrait peut-être éviter
ces chats mariage là mais sur la
question du transfert en santé qui n'est
pas aussi quand même intéressant de
noter que dans ce budget on se vante le
que la croissance serait de à peu près
quatre points 8 % si je me souviens bien
mais il faut comprendre que c'est pas
parce qu'on est plus généreux c'est
simplement qu'on applique la formule de
croissance prévu depuis longtemps et ça
adonne parce qu'il ya de la croissance
parce qu'il ya de l'inflation que sur sa
folle remontée le transfert comme tel il
n'y a aucun gain pour les provinces en
ce moment très bien j'ai beaucoup parlé
en haut avec gérald est soit du celi
alors je vais je dirais pas là avec vous
mais ça a été plutôt
la défense la défense
est ce que là encore il y avait le jeu
des attentes chantal puis il y en a
moins que ce qu'on aurait pu croire il
ya
un petit point sur la santé quand même
monsieur trudeau est favorisée par le
cercle élections en ontario élections
québec qui rencontrera pas vraiment les
provinces là dessus avant la fin de
l'automne prochain cette calendrier qui
dit ça sur la défense ce qui avait de
plus intéressant dans le budget selon
moi avait rien à voir avec le budget
c'est peut-être ce qui avait de plus
rassurant c'est à dire qu'on va faire
une révision de la politique canadienne
en matière de défense ce qu'on aurait
pas fait depuis des lunes demande de
changer et on n'a jamais ajusté et ça
vaut pour le rappeur on n'a jamais
acheté nos priorités avant de se lancer
dans des immenses dépenses ce serait
bien savoir comment on voit notre
défense dans l'univers après le trump
rétro game micros étaient là ce serait
bien terreau ce qu'on veut faire avant
d'acheter des choses qu'ils coûtent alec
vous le savez vous avez couvert beaucoup
sont très chers oui absolument vous
savez le point si longtemps on parlait
d' état en faillite de guerre
asymétrique de terrorisme et c'est à ça
qu'on voulait préparer l'armée
canadienne l'on parle de guerre
conventionnelle en europe qu'on n'avait
pas vu depuis la seconde guerre mondiale
c'est pas le même type d'équipement a
c'est pas le même type de spécialités
alors qu'est ce qu'on voit dans le futur
faudrait ajouter en conséquence j'ai
bien des gens qui se disent peut-être
que l'armée canadienne étant donné sa
taille son influence assez limité dans
le monde devrait se spécialiser dans
certains créneaux très précis ne pas
penser qu'on peut dépenser comme les
américains pour autant des avions des
sous marins des bateaux des chars
d'assaut d'aller dans certains créneaux
ça serait bien de définir quelque chose
dans ce sens là et que les autres partis
d'opposition et puis pour qu'on arrête à
chaque fois qu'on change de parti de
changer de politique de défense la
continuité oui oui non les f 35
ça coûte tellement d'argent ces
acquisitions la caisse a tout les sens
et quand on décide qu'on reproche la
soupe qu'on recommence le sénat c'est
normal que tout déraille à chaque fois
donc d'avoir quelque chose d'un peu plus
non partisan
quand collégialité que les autres partis
ça éviterait aussi sont donc dans la
réflexion ça pourrait être intéressant
le temps on y revient le luxe du temps
de pouvoir prendre le temps de réfléchir
avant de d'agir un mot quand même sur
baie du nord dont c'était hier mais
c'est une beau est-ce qu'on à l'extrait
de monsieur guilbeault d'hyères on va
écouter monsieur guilbeault qui nous
disait on le sentait là il peut pas
mentir à ce point là il n'était pas à
l'aise avec la désormais on écoute
sédition quitté évidemment très
difficile comme on en prendrait lance
souvent dans lorsqu'en gouverne le pays
de 37 millions de personnes soit étant
nous avons nous sommes engagées lorsque
nous avons réformé le processus
d'évaluation environnementale de la
dépolitiser ce exactement ce que nous
avons fait avec l'évaluation
environnementale et là je viens un
groupe d'experts qui étudie le projet
pendant quatre ans et qui me fait une
recommandation examens nous on estime
que le projet n'a pas d'impact
significatif
bon tour de table rapide est ce que
c'est un boulet qu'ils vont traîner oui
ou non on chanta
probablement moins parce que le timing
en politique ça compte et on est dans un
moment où l'opinion publique est
préoccupé par le l'augmentation des
codes coheed préoccupé par la guerre
nucléaire avec deux semaines de l'allant
show parlement et annoncé la veille du
budget la preuve c'est qu'on en parle et
que le temps manquait ou était je suis
certaine que monsieur guilbeault était
vraiment pas content d'avoir à faire
cette annonce il avait été que de lui il
n'aurait pas accepté ce projet mais
c'était un peu écrit dans le ciel parce
que que ce projet allait être adoptée
par ce que il est beaucoup moins
polluant que les autres projets de
pétroliers au canada par exemple on nous
dit que dans l'intensité de ces dix fois
moins polluant pour barry pour barry que
les sables bitumineux alors dire non à
ce projet aurait été envoyé le message
que désormais plus aucun projet de
pétroliers ne sera acceptée au canada
chez bien que les environnementalistes
c'est ce qui le demandent mais ce n'est
pas la position du parti libéral qui
pense que on peut peut-être continuer à
augmenter la production aussi en bout de
piste les émissions elle se stabilise
alors ça ne m'étonne pas monsieur
guilbeault est certainement pas content
mais c'est une décision qui se défend
compte tenu de la position libérale qui
est de quand même défendre la production
pétrolière amusé transition voilà alec
mois et compte tenu de la situation
économique à terre-neuve faut pas
l'oublier ça pèse dans le ça pèse
certainement dans cette décision le 6 on
pouvait prendre des projets comme
celui-là est remplacé ses projets lors
des sables bitumineux qui sont beaucoup
plus populaires on le ferait évidemment
c'est pour ce qui va se produire mais
l'un pour l'autre c'est vrai que c'est
beaucoup moins beaucoup moins polluant
que les sables bitumineux oblique que
hier ça c'est passé inaperçu mais au
même moment steven guilbeault a dit non
à un autre projet le djia l'entrevue
être celui de suncor donc il là un
espèce d'équilibré on cherche à avoir
qui paraît pas toujours très bien
évidemment parce que là on a trouvé un
nouveau projet mais qui dans le fond
peut-être que cet échange l'or sur le
long terme vaut la peine et oui ça va
être critiqué c'est clair merci beaucoup
à vous trois très intéressant merci
chantal hélène avec à la prochaine au
revoir au revoir au rebond pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit